that's a bit late here welcome to this
video playing a 15 minute game against
tamala from Finland yeah absolutely the
opposition at the moment is even a
lighter than it usually is 1500 is
remarkably low but while you never know
some of those games are not so easy
let's see is playing the improved tirage
but now it transporting to the pure Tosh
and in fact in a version that it's not
so great with the only night f6 Bishop
g5 is some is good here you see the
problem his d5 pawn is somewhat yeah is
directly under fire yeah I can just take
it out so out of the opening i have appt
you an extra pawn or maybe even to wait
just a moment yeah i can just take this
really and let's consider can i or
should i just play g g3 and Bishop g2
yeah come on let's not be too
materialistic I could have played Bishop
e3 even to keep the porn but i rather
develop pieces i have a point anyway
even if he takes you five I have an
extra point and okay i can take g5 now
right and then e7 this night c7 grabbing
yeah
so take here okay so how to keep the
pawn on c5 maybe just just play before a
five does even be five yeah I know
Bishop g2 is some looking very very
logical but one everyone it's actually
better placed in comparison because it
supports the pawns when they advance
this forces the trade taking here and
every capture
near the pond see em they they win on on
their own really through q1 next check
then probably look to d6 as a good
square
the most active square the rook is
entering and black really has no means
there should be seven does Luke Graham
b6
okay so hmm I don't want to trade really
and no this would improve this pawn
structure but attacking a three that's
really not necessary again okay it's the
bishop endgame is in general minor piece
end games with with extra material is
the best bet to win besides opposite
colored bishops of course but like here
same colored bishops and you have a pawn
or in this case there's even two ponds
you almost invariably will win if there
is nothing special going on and yeah
here there is really nothing that that
black hairs okay maybe this is the
easiest getting the a porn yeah or now I
get checked I get two passes check young
black resigns yeah five minute five
minutes for a 15 minute game but there's
still some some information here and
this is the opening i can tell you
something about this opening because it
is rising time and time again this
precise position is arising many times
in queen pawn openings in the Queens
gambit also from other move orders if we
consider something like this for example
that's a stupid before I wanted to do
this in fact here here knight c6 is
absolutely the best move Knight f6 is
bad and this is exactly what we had in
the game if we consider just a different
new order here black must take with the
with the night leading to the so-called
improved tirage or semi tirage
what he did takes leads to the mentioned
version of the tirage which is not so
great and the problem is that Bishop g5
just spoke include reasons is a strong
move white threatens to take and destroy
the pawn structure or win the porn so
yeah let's just say this is completely
we don't take but this is the point or
GF which looks like well Swiss cheese
information so like really only has
moves like a Bishop e7 orbital b6 if you
go as Bishop e7 this is the game white
will take and now the problem is that d
5 is not easily am yeah c5 I mean it's
not easily recaptured and why it has a
very direct pressure against the spawn
very often after the bishop takes you
get this type of palm rep wear black
compensation is absolutely non-existent
so on this is a good line d takes d5 and
the other opportunity is bishop e60
black and here it's very important to
know that while you can still play small
things like III or if those positional
moves that e form or taking on f6 and
then you form is rather strong it just
grabs a big space in the center and it
can easily happen that in in a situation
like this white gets an enormous
development advantage that is very
difficult form for black to to combat
something like that can easily lead to
black going down quickly there's the
famous game by amarela kind in this line
i think even more than one before is the
important movement it's really happening
in games this happened to me in a
tournament game once was pretty
surprised that you get this on the board
but it happens and here the only
question is if or now or first taking
taking first has maybe the advantage
that after before there is the
at least theoretical possibility of
Bishop e7 being played and you maybe
don't want that so it's probably a
matter of taste what you were to do but
maybe Bishop f6 is even stronger than
Ella currency forward it's important to
not play a lame move like this here
black and play c4 for example and keep
the the whole thing close this is not so
great in comparison and this formation
you rather have your Bishop on g2 so you
need to punish a black quickly yo-yo in
the game after this d 4 is just just a
bit strange because I just take it he
probably should play something back like
this but this is a move I mean maybe I
can just do that and keep the porn yeah
it's not a good line for black but
important to know for the white player
because you really get it quite
frequently especially in blitz chess
where sometimes people are just playing
their moves quickly and they forgot
about the the subtle point okay thanks
for watching